how are you handling this whole zoom
thing because i've had the privilege of
speaking to you
many times in person you're great
conversationalist you're very funny
how do you feel like it's working for
you on zoom
oh it's uh it's tough tough to accept
this is the way you know but uh
but uh i'm doing it there's there's good
things about it i'm not intimidated
by your height you know um
that is that is nice
same size on the frame you know i do my
own camera i don't have your people you
know
boycotting me at all but uh
you also when we've talked in the past
you do comment on my giant head
and how it it it's unsettling to you it
must be nice now to see my head in a
more normal way
definitely definitely it is it is
it brings me peace uh and
i don't know i i get very anxious and
nervous be before
going on a talk show with you and and
it's uh
it's nice to be on zoom you know i can
blame the connection
don't speak english the way you do it's
my i mean
it's it's not the language i grew up
with so i have to pretend i
understand every joke you make you know
when i'm with you and now i can just say
like oh
sorry what was that oh my connection
so you're blaming it all on your wi-fi
the fact that you
that you don't like my jokes okay i like
them i mean they seem funny people
seem to laugh it's just that i don't get
them
well that's apparently true for many
americans uh as well
you know we always have a tradition
whenever we're together we drink mezcal
together and we didn't want that to get
in the way just because i think you're
in london right now
i am and you're uh working on a very
top-secret project
and i'm here in los angeles i i don't
know about you i brought
some mezcal i'm going to have a shot of
mezcal do you have mascara with you
always i mean always okay you carry it
with you
i say we do a shot right now i hope your
your glass is the the the right glass
for mezcal you know it has to be
you said it has to be short yeah two
years stop
okay i'm going to go smaller than that
it's early here it's night time for you
it is nighttime for me it's like the
morning for you
but i guess you drink every morning
right so yes you would assume that
that's what the irish do
um listen uh i want to say uh diego
here's to you
uh is familia and
gente de mexico all the people of mexico
oh salud
let's do it oh
ah wow you did it the the american way
yeah
i mean you have a long show i mean you
don't have to just go for it
i thought it was supposed to go for it
no no
not at all not mexican then buy cheap
cheap tequila or something else it's
burning
it's burning my lungs and my chest right
now
oh my god i thought oh you're just
skipping it yeah you gotta skip it
i want to make another toast if you
don't mind and i guess you don't you
already okay here we go here's another
toast
another toast for the new win of joe
biden today
yes yes the winner of joe biden today i
will toast to that too
yeah oh
holy crap oh this interview is going to
be
are you okay it burns it burns
and it's this one shouldn't burn
but you're drinking like you know like a
spring breaker
relax i mean i could sip it as what
you're saying
i i forgot eight years for the plant to
grow and you just have it in a second
like i know i'm disrespecting the mezcal
i don't mean to
yeah and you're talking about are we
talking about
diego where are you what were we talking
about